the climate crisis affects us all and we
all have the power to help solve it the
science community all around the world's
been telling us for a long time we have
to yes but let's take a look at why the
sky is a very thin shell of atmosphere
surrounding the planet and we're putting
into that thin space a hundred and ten
million tons of manmade global warming
pollution every 24 hours and it's
building up and it's trapping heat the
energy from the Sun comes in the form of
light and it warms up the planet and
then that heat energy is reradiating
back into space and some of it is caught
by the natural greenhouse gas layer and
that's a good thing but we're making
that layer much thicker so more of the
outgoing infrared is being trapped and
that's what is driving the temperatures
up and there are many causes of manmade
global warming pollution
agriculture is a part of it and the
management of forests and transportation
but the main part of it is the burning
of fossil fuels which provides more than
80 percent of all the energy the world
uses as a result all this heats being
trapped and the air temperatures going
up quite dramatically and this is
causing record-breaking year 16 of the
17 hottest years ever measured with
instruments have been since 2001 but on
a global basis more than 90 percent of
all this extra heat energy is going into
the oceans and they're heating up pretty
rapidly and this makes the ocean based
storms like hurricanes and typhoons and
cyclones stronger and more destructive
and it also disrupts the water cycle
because the water vapor coming off the
oceans is increasing very significantly
as the oceans warm and that's carried
over the land and falls in much bigger
precipitation events both rain and snow
so we get these wreck
downpours and that leads to record
flooding and the same extra heat that's
disrupting the water cycle and making
the downpours bigger is sucking the
moisture out of the soil and making the
droughts deeper and longer and more
destructive and when the land dries out
the vegetation dries out and that means
when the temperature goes up fires
increase now we have these mega fires
now same he is also melting the ice in
Antarctica and here in Greenland this is
a huge glacier in the last century and
completely melted now and all that extra
melting is raising sea level the
Department of Defense in the US has long
warned about refugee crises connected to
the climate crisis and pandemic diseases
and water shortages and food shortages
where food is concerned the extra heat
stress is now beginning to decrease crop
yields it's also a medical emergency and
with temperatures going up and the
climate being disrupted we're seeing
tropical diseases spreading poet of
course the transportation revolution and
air travel has a lot to do with this the
biologists are also concerned about the
extinction threat up to half of all the
land-based species with which we share
this planet are in danger of extinction
according to the biologists in this
century unless we make changes so do we
have to change yes we do but fortunately
every hour the earth gets as much energy
from the Sun to supply all of the energy
the entire global economy uses for an
entire year there's an exponential curve
with wind power being used all over the
world and it could supply 40 times as
much electricity as the entire world use
it at the Paris negotiations virtually
every nation in the entire world agreed
to phase down greenhouse gas pollution
to Net Zero emission
says early in the second half of this
century as possible and we're seeing
marches and demonstrations and demands
at the ballot box for the kinds of
changes that are needed so please use
your voice and your vote and your
choices in the marketplace and in your
life like your world depends on it
because your world depends on it
thank you thank you